So today what I want to do was talk
about the revolutions of 1848 and read,
you know,
read the chapter.
It's not very long.
Um,
and I want to talk principally about why
there was no revolution in Britain in
1848 since there were
revolutions in France,
in Austria in the halfway or domains of,
of,
uh,
um,
you know,
the Austrian empire of
what would become an 1867,
Austria,
Hungary,
uh,
in,
in Prussia,
uh,
and in the Rhineland and in I,
in northern Italy,
and even central Italy,
but not in Britain and
want to talk about that.
But before I do that,
um,
let's just think about revolution
in general and how revolutions work.
And I'll mention this
again when we get to,
um,
uh,
to the Russian revolution.
And if you think about what you know
about the French Revolution in this
context,
uh,
hopefully it'll make some sense.
And in the 18th,
in the 1960s,
um,
uh,
people,
social scientists
believe that revolutions,
many social sciences,
it's not all believe that revolutions
hurricane when pressure builds up and
you've got pretty soon
intellectuals bailing out,
leaving the regime and then you've got
all this tension building up and then
boom,
you've got your basic revolution.
But revolutions don't work like that.
If you think about revolutions,
you know,
anything about the Iranian revolution
in 1979 would be a good example.
Or,
um,
the revolutions we're going to
talk about today a little bit,
it's you're reading about
1848 or the French revolution.
What happens is that,
uh,
in the case of 1848 or in the case of,
of the other ones that I've
mentioned is that there is a,
you know,
a seizure of power by a group,
uh,
who may have come together because
they oppose the policies of,
of,
of the establish of the government in,
in power.
But it's at that point that you've got
an increase in social and political
tension,
and it's at that point
that you've got this,
this,
that,
that tension really increases and,
and all sorts of interesting
things begin to happen.
Um,
so in the case of 1917,
uh,
in Saint Petersburg in February,
the bread lines are very long a,
they're not a lot of troops
around there at the front.
They're not a lot of police around.
Uh,
and suddenly,
uh,
the,
the czar czarist regime is just
sort of swept away like that.
And it's at that point
that things heat up.
Um,
the 1917 things weren't any,
you know,
tenser than were 19,
16 and,
and there's a lot of things happen.
A visa vi the war that,
that help people mobilize,
tried to imagine a post czarist
world or a reformed czar,
uh,
czarist autocracy.
Um,
in the case of 1848,
you know,
you've got your basic,
uh,
you've got demonstrations
in Paris in February.
It's rains all the time in Paris.
In February,
it's gray.
Uh,
people want a electoral reform.
And then the troops opened up
and shoot a bunch of people.
The same thing that happens in
Berlin that long after that.
And at that point then you've
got the regime was swept away.
But what's interesting about revolutionary
process is that after you've got this
kind of basic provisional
government in the case of all,
which is what were the constitutional
monarchy in 1789 and 1790 becomes,
uh,
and in the case of currencies,
provisional government in 1917 and
in the case of this kind of moderate
republic,
uh,
in France,
it's at that point,
or in Germany or in Austria,
you still got the monarchy,
but did you have all these contenders
for power who are saying at that point,
we want to take advantage
of the situation,
uh,
so that we will have a republic or the,
in the case of France,
that women will have more rights or
the workers will have more rights.
Uh,
in the case of,
of a,
of Germany,
uh,
of the German states,
people who want a unified Germany
put forth their claims at that point.
Uh,
in the case of France,
people who want the monarchy,
uh,
the borbons that is the legitimate
who were chased out in 1830.
Do you want them back?
They could in their claims,
you've got your basic
moderate Republicans.
They're saying,
we want a moderate republic.
Uh,
uh,
and in the case of,
of,
uh,
of Australia,
you've got all these Vini
students and they want reforms.
They want to progressive regime.
So it's at that point that the sort of
social tension and political tension
increases and what the
revolutionary process does is it,
and what's important about 1848 is that
it brings for the first time lots more
people into the political process.
Uh,
that in the case of France,
my a friend Maurice Og,
you know,
has called the second republic.
That is 1848 to 18 of,
well fifth,
December 2nd,
1851 and really 1852,
uh,
the apprenticeship of the republic
because now you've got universal manhood,
suffrage.
All men can vote.
Lots of women want to vote tool,
but that it's not a dominant discourse,
but it's still important,
uh,
in Paris.
Um,
and so you have a politicization of
ordinary people and you have this in the
German states.
You have it in the Italian states
as well and you haven't Austria,
Hungary,
um,
in the case of lost you're hungry.
Cause then you've got,
you know,
Hungarians putting four claims,
special claims within
the Hasbrook domains and,
and the national question
surfaces in central Europe.
Uh,
and in,
uh,
in Italy where people can
imagine a unifying Italy,
a unified Italy,
which would mean you have to get rid
of the Austrians basically there.
And you can read about
what happened subsequently.
But so you have these,
these,
these people putting forth their claims.
And so you have this
remarkable politicization.
In the case of Paris,
you know,
the barricades go up,
which happened in February.
And then the June days follow,
which is a sort of a,
basically a class war in which
lots of people get killed,
uh,
and put in prison and massive,
massive,
uh,
unrest in the law three days in June,
1848.
And that's a much more violent
confrontation and telling confrontation.
Then the initial revolutionary seizure
of power by groups who don't necessarily
agree on what's going to happen.
But in the case of France,
which is a,
again,
the best documented,
you've got all of these newspapers that
begin publishing because now suddenly
you can publish things and you've
got all these political clubs.
Just as an 1848,
you've got Neil Jacobin clubs,
you've got,
you know,
clubs of women,
uh,
that you've got the club of
the two sexes as it's called.
Uh,
and,
and so this beef becomes a way of,
of,
of politicizing ordinary people.
So when men go to the polls in 1848,
I in April for the first time,
and they elect a relatively,
um,
conservative indeed monarchists
leaning National Assembly,
but they do so with,
with,
uh,
with a considerable
knowledge about what the,
what,
you know,
what they want.
I mean,
they want school teachers,
they want credit available.
Uh,
you know,
they want the right to vote.
And so this politicization or
the apprenticeship of republic,
it would finally be,
be permanent.
Starting in the 1870s,
uh,
is one of the most important aspects of,
of the revolution.
The same thing of the Russian revolution,
which I'll come back and talk about.
You've got,
you know,
you've got Mensheviks,
you got Bolsheviks,
you've got socialist revolutionaries.
These are three big radical groups.
Uh,
you've got constitutional democrats.
you've got monarchists,
you've got people who want the czar and
have all the power that he had before,
and a lock off the heads of those people
who are against him and that kind of
thing.
So,
uh,
and then the case of
the Russian revolution,
how you get from the February revolution
to October when the Bolsheviks seized
power is,
is really very fascinating.
Um,
so that's just the way of
thinking about revolution.
And you can think about
other revolutions that,
you know,
uh,
but,
the point is that it,
that,
that the revolution as a
process it's brings into a,
brings into play,
uh,
the aspirations of a lot more people.
And in the case,
the French case,
uh,
which I,
which is fascinating,
is what begins as kind of an urban,
it's her middleclass revolution.
And people fought by artisans as usual,
uh,
who want the right to vote.
And the up in December,
1851 after Napoleon's nephew,
Louis Napoleon Bonaparte,
who had become good old Napoleon third,
not so good old,
but he destroys the republic where he
completes the process of repression that
he'd already,
uh,
as President France elected
on the 10th of December,
1848 initiated.
Um,
but that very ordinary people,
peasants,
uh,
for the most part,
but also rural artisans and
particularly in the south,
and not necessarily
speaking French at all,
rise up to try to defend the
republic or what they call it,
a lot better.
Uh,
the beautiful one,
uh,
against the rape as they called it,
by,
uh,
by the repressive apparatus
centered in Paris.
And so this,
this rural,
there's urban revolution ends up with
over 100,000 people taking arms in the
largest national instruction
in France in the 19th century,
trying to defend the republic against
its abolition by Louis Napoleon Bonaparte
who would not be,
would not be able to stand for a second
term as president of the republic.
And that's really fascinating.
Especially,
Jeez,
a long time ago,
I used to read all these
interrogations of people,
including what the uncle or great,
great,
great uncle of one of our neighbors,
you know,
and it's being translated from,
from Oak,
see Tom,
which is,
you know,
the language of that part of the south
in the French by some translators.
He's being interrogated.
When did you join the secret society?
When did,
who did you initiate into
the secret society to defend,
you know,
defend the republic,
the social and,
uh,
the,
the democratic and social republic,
a social republic that's going to
provide more things to more people,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Fascinating.
The politicization of this.
Now in the case of,
of,
of Germany and Italy,
um,
it,
you know,
it's a,
it's a different kind of,
of,
um,
uh,
of revolution.
It still had its kind of liberal and,
and democratic component.
Um,
but you had this scene,
for example,
in the,
in Frankfurt,
in the Frankford parliament,
which was this,
you know,
sort of basically,
uh,
a lot of professors and lawyers debating
long into the night in Saint Paul's
Church.
You know,
and they imagine the
unification of Germany,
uh,
what they called them,
the spring time of the peoples,
uh,
that Germany,
the German states in which pressure,
you know,
sacs knee a Bavaria were
where the inadvertent Berg,
where the most important of these states.
Um,
but all these other little states,
two are going to be unified along,
um,
uh,
a liberal ospices.
And of course,
they were just dreaming.
Uh,
and in the end they
were kind of dismissed.
Uh,
uh,
Eh,
you know,
as a,
a servant who was not
wanting to be kept on by,
by the,
at the big house anymore.
Uh,
they're sort of dismissed,
but they debate far into the night.
Uh,
and the significance of all of this
is when you read the chapter on,
please do on the second Republican,
you see what happens in the,
in the case of the German states is that
when Germany would be unified and that
unification is proclaimed in January,
uh,
1871 in Versailles,
in the chateau Versailles,
after the Franco Prussian war,
it would not be a liberal unification.
It would not be a Germany,
United by,
by lawyers and professors,
uh,
meeting in a frock for church,
with what would become
eventually the German flag,
the colors of it through
hanging all around the rafters.
Uh,
it would be unified as Bismark,
accurately put it by blood and
iron in the context of depression.
Uh,
aristocracy,
the nobles,
the Yonkers,
a term you already know,
Yonkers,
the Prussian Nobles.
Um,
and that basically unified Germany,
uh,
would be as some wag once put it,
an army with a state trailing behind it.
Uh,
and Germany would not be a republic.
It would be an empire.
Uh,
and because one of the things that happens
with empires is an emperor's can do
whatever they damn well
please just the czar's Ken.
And you might've had an assembly
called though high stock,
which had a lot of the
which socialists became the,
the leaders are the most dominant,
uh,
it numerically by 1914,
but power rests in the hands
of a thoroughly irresponsible,
intellectually lazy.
So mad cap,
uh,
ridiculous guy who happens
to be the Kaiser Wilhelm.
The second and so over the long run,
the cost to Europe of that fact,
uh,
would be in retrospect,
given what happens in the 20th century,
which is the one that follows the 19th,
uh,
would be one thing that,
that historians would go back and
say very a very obvious things is,
are cliches like,
well,
in 1848,
uh,
history in Germany reached its
turning point and failed to turn,
uh,
that Germany unification
would not come because of,
um,
because of professors and,
and Liberals and merchants in
Homburg and this sort of thing.
And that the middle class is a German
middle classes would in a way abdicate
their political responsibility and
not having much political power.
And the state would be
really run by a bunch of,
uh,
of,
Younkers a of military officers with
dueling scars and veterans of the
fraternity's of the,
uh,
of,
you know,
the Prussian universities
and pressure was,
isn't just,
or it wasn't just Pomerania in
Brandenburg and sort of the marshes of,
of,
of northern,
uh,
of North Eastern Europe,
but Prussia also controlled the Rheinland.
Uh,
but the,
the kind of magnates of,
of industrializing,
uh,
pressure,
we're not going to be the ones who are
running the show in the case of Italy.
I mean,
the news you could read
about that too is that,
uh,
you know,
there are a lot of people running around
saying long live United Italy and all
of this business.
But that was to be very hard to,
because in order to unify
Italy under any auspices I,
most people wanted under liberal ospices,
um,
you have to get rid of who you have to
get rid of the Austrians because the
Austrians control much of,
almost all of northern Italy
and much of central Italy too.
So there are lots of,
of impediments to Italian unification.
Uh,
none of the,
not the least of which was the
fact that the vast majority of,
of people in,
in Italy did not speak Italian.
That itself was not a,
uh,
not a,
you know,
a,
a major impediment.
But it,
you know,
I guess it was to only about four or 5%
of the people in Italy spoke what now is
to be Italian,
which I guess is,
I don't speak Italian,
but I guess that's essentially
the language of Tuscany
or the area around around
Florence.
And they spoke all sorts
of other dialects and,
and,
and the Tuscan language was virtually
unknown in the south of Italy or
insistently and was identified with,
you know,
sort of money grabbing tax collectors
coming down from the north.
And so,
uh,
after the,
the tide of the,
the springtime of the people or somebody
once called the great illusion also,
uh,
of 1848,
after that tide had passed,
what you had is still,
uh,
the,
lots of,
of,
of fervin hopes and dreams that
Italy was going to be unified,
um,
along liberal ospices.
And indeed that is what happens even
though it's a monarchy and unification
comes because of basically the expansion
of the state of Piedmont Sardinia,
which was that most influenced by,
by the French wave in the times
of the French revolution and of,
of Napoleon.
And also the wealthiest part of Italy,
uh,
in,
in the case of Austria,
Austria,
Hungary.
Well,
I mean,
there's a long story and
you can read about it,
but the springtime of the people's meant,
uh,
the dreams first of number
of nationalities now talk
about nationalism and the
weaker to who suddenly think that
now they too will have their time.
And,
and the somebody,
people,
a bunch of check nationalists were
sitting in a room rather like this and
somebody looked up and said,
Jesus,
if this ceiling collapses,
that's the end of the
Czech national movement.
Uh,
and two or something to that.
So the springtime of the peoples,
uh,
would not bring,
you know,
we're not bring an
independent check state.
It wouldn't bring a,
you know,
a checklist of lochea
which only lasts til,
uh,
1993,
despite with John Mccain thinks,
uh,
um,
you know,
it doesn't come told 19,
uh,
1918 after world war one.
But,
but in the Austrian Guerin empire,
you know,
everybody says,
well,
you know what,
what if we have a independent
Felicia or what if we,
you know,
Poland is,
is independent in the parts of,
of,
uh,
of a Russian and Austrian Poland.
Uh,
uh,
we'll be independent.
But these,
these are,
these are pipe dreams and,
and,
uh,
and national awareness and,
and great power of politics will mean
that this isn't going to happen until
later.
Pull them,
becomes independent in 1918 for
reasons that you already know.
And that the,
the,
when the chill of reaction,
I mean,
revolution,
reaction,
repression,
uh,
is the,
is what really happens in the,
that's the theme running through the
whole thing besides the big hopes of,
of the spring of 1848
and the kind of Austrian,
uh,
the Austrian imperial system a run.
And I'll come back and talk about Austria.
Hungary quite a bit,
run in German in the polyglot,
Austrian Hungarian Empire where
they're at least 15 major languages,
uh,
will be the story of Austria,
Hungary in the 1850.
And of course the Hungarians get,
get,
uh,
get separate status,
equal status in principle as of 18,
uh,
1867.
And of course one of the strange,
not strange,
but one of the interesting things about
the Austrian gerund period is that it's
an 1848 that friends funds Joseph
becomes emperor of Austria,
Hungary,
and he is in power until 1916.
He is around even longer than
Victoria than Queen Victoria.
Uh,
and I mean the world changes
in such dramatic ways
between riff between 1848 and
1916 when I was younger than you.
Um,
I was in Vienna for the first time and
I was sitting in some coffee shop as one
does there and a cafe,
and this is a very old man started talking
to me and he had actually seen when
he was young,
had seen funds Yosef.
And that was the most amazing thing for
me to actually meet somebody who had
seen when he was a boyfriend.
Joseph.
I mean,
that's just extraordinary continuity.
But anyway,
that's another story.
Oster Henry's another story and it's an
interesting one and a that we're going
to come back to,
but I can't do that now.
We've got to talk to go
back to the question of,
of,
of uh,
of England,
but,
but also another of the,
I mean of the legacies of this is that,
you know,
after this tide of reaction,
what it does is it sends waves of
political refugees to places like this.
Not New haven so much.
But yeah,
and there were some Italians
end up in new haven who,
Italian political refugees in that period,
but lots of Germans who are of course
thrown out of the German states,
uh,
and had better not come back.
They ended up where they end up in
Philadelphia or in New York and lots of
Irish,
well,
I'm going to talk about it in a minute.
Ends up in obvious places,
Boston,
New York,
those two above all,
but also Philadelphia.
And so the,
the glacial wave of
repression sends these people,
a lot of them to,
uh,
the United States,
that,
that itself is an interesting stories.
So,
although the revolutions of 1848
failed and you should read about that,
please do.
God,
I love this stuff.
Talking about this,
uh,
the political legacies that they left our,
um,
you know,
extremely important and these,
these demands for political rights would
be something that would last for a very
long time.
And again,
to repeat into and this little
part of what we're doing home.
My goodness now I,
that that German unification would come
under very different auspices that,
that those than that of
the revolutionaries in 1848
what they wanted and that,
that the,
the,
the king of Prussia rejects this crown
offered from the gutter as he called it
to unify Germany under a
liberal monarchical auspices.
That ain't going to happen and it doesn't.
Okay.
There's revolution and
all these places in 1848,
the big wave,
but why not in
or why not?
You probably already
know some of the answers.
Now,
the context,
uh,
they're really two major
context in all of this.
The first is that the reform act
of 1832 opens the drawbridge,
puts down the drawbridge
and opens it to more voters.
More people can vote.
Now,
uh,
again,
voting was based upon
property qualification.
Uh,
you,
um,
uh,
I guess it was Fergus,
Oh,
con,
uh,
O'connor who was a,
Irish,
uh,
in move chartist and we'll
talk about in a minute.
Uh,
he,
he didn't even have the right to a,
he is dis not disbarred,
but he's really tall,
thrown out of,
of parliament because it doesn't
make enough money in order to,
to actually qualify to vote himself.
Uh,
you could vote if you paid
x number of pounds in,
uh,
in shillings,
in taxes.
Uh,
and so what happens is the 1832 opens up,
uh,
the,
the drawbridge and more people can vote.
The political arena expands a little bit
in the same thing happens in France in
1830.
As you know,
in France,
the revolution of 1830 doubled the
number of people that could vote.
But it still leaves lots of
people on the outside looking in.
And in 1867 they would pass
a second reform bill that
lets more people in and an
1884 they pass another one that
lets almost everybody in a,
except for I think a domestic servants
and and maybe rural proletarians I can't
remember exactly but so what the political
arena is expanding and the point of
this is,
is expanding through reform that
Britain reforms and that the self image,
the self identity of the
free born Englishman tracing,
you know,
more or less at least in the imaginary,
I antecedents back to June 15th,
1215 at Runnymede near London.
The idea that the free born Englishman
has rights and that we British citizens,
our identity,
we reform.
We don't rebel.
And clearly as I will demonstrate in
a minute a drawing on the work of John
Belcher and other people to uh,
that what happens in,
in,
in 1848 is when there might have
been a revolutionary moment in,
in Britain that France has sneezed in.
Europe is catching a cold as they
like to say over and over again.
It doesn't come to a Britain,
but that British national identity,
like all national identities have
to be systematically reinvented and
reconstructed.
And that this happens in 1848
in subsequent years as well.
That the sense that we are
respectable and respectability,
I've written up on the board,
uh,
that,
um,
uh,
it means reform and not revolution now.
Uh,
and that the aristocracy of labor
who were craftsmen and artisans slash
craftsman who could be seen
walking through Hyde Park
with their ladies on their
arms wearing suits of
all things on Sundays,
that bourgeois respectability,
uh,
had a political,
a political aspect of it too.
And so in 1848,
Britain does not,
uh,
w does not rebel.
Um,
now the other ad out more
about this in a minute,
the eye,
the other context that of
course charters ism would,
you should read about
now Chartis campaign.
There were campaigns to get ordinary
people to sign an enormous charter with
millions and millions of names.
There's a too big waves
in the 1830s and forties.
And what they do is
they sign and they say,
Oh,
humble,
we,
we the humble,
poor we ordinary people.
We in treat you,
you know,
big time lords,
property owners of great distinction
who are representing a property in
parliament.
We entreat you to give us political
rights and they bring these petitions,
these huge petitions.
They bring in them on wagons
signed by Zillions of people,
many of whom can only mark an x instead
of write their names and they bring them
to parliament in the rain as always.
And parliaments says,
Gee,
thanks a lot.
We don't want to see that.
And then they say,
oh well we'll do it again.
Oh Great.
Lords give us political rights.
And so they sign,
you know,
they don't pick up their blunder buses.
They sign a,
in 1830,
the French middleclass was more than
happy to turn the artisans loose on the
street to fight their battles
for them for political reform.
And delicate was famous painting
liberty leads the people,
the bourgeois with his top hat.
Uh,
it doesn't have any in
this romantic picture.
Romanticized view of revolution does not
have any place there because the bush
was,
he does not fight unless you
consider art master artisans,
you know,
petty bourgeois.
But in England,
that's never going to happen.
And the charters campaign
remains respectable.
It is,
uh,
it is,
it,
you know,
it's class based to the extent
that most people who signed the,
the chartist petitions
are ordinary people.
But what,
what really,
they saw themselves as moral reformers.
They see themselves as trying to do,
and it cuts across class lines.
They're trying to get the
government to do the right thing,
to pass more reforms.
The,
the,
the reform act of 1832 was passed by a
conservative government because they knew
that negatively it was gonna it
was going to have to be passed,
or who knows?
It would create more
lords in order to end.
You'd have these sort of,
not real lords were there.
So the bill gets passed and so it's
passed by a conservative government.
And then everybody says,
oh,
well we British,
we reform,
we've opened up the drawbridge more.
More people can vote.
Now.
There was a component of Chartis who
are called physical force chartists and
the,
and they,
you know,
they're not so sure that,
that,
that reform without
revolution as possible,
but they are a minority
within the charter movement.
They are a very small minority,
the physical force charters.
So what you've got in 1848 is you
got two things that are going on.
First of all,
you,
you don't have a revolution.
There's this big date in,
um,
in April,
I think it's April 10th,
where there's going to be
this huge march in London.
So what the government does is it
deputizes 25,000 men of property,
they become sheriffs to become,
you know,
I don't know what you call them.
Yeah.
I get sheriffs,
I guess.
And Louis Napoleon Bonaparte
who happened to be in,
you know,
we had not yet returned to France.
He was worth,
it was,
it was actually deputized as a sheriff.
And so the business people in the city,
which is what,
you know,
the financial capital of,
of the,
the overlooks the British empire,
I was increasingly called,
they come with their hunting rifles to
work and they get those file cabinets
ready to barricade the door and with
their rifles and they're going to blow
apart anybody who rises up,
uh,
and would challenge a British,
who had tried to bring revolution to,
uh,
to,
to Britain it,
and there's 25,000 of these people,
uh,
and the number of marchers was,
was far,
far small to that.
And it's a smaller than that
and it's a very peaceful march.
There is no revolution in Britain in 1848.
But if there hadn't been a revolution,
where would it come from?
From,
from where would the
revolutionaries ranks have come?
And that is the interesting question.
That's the by far the most interesting
question and all of this because what I
said before about 1848 helps the British,
um,
re invent or reconfigure,
reconstruct their identity that there
has to be an unwanted other there who's
frightening them,
who makes them convinced even more
that they're doing it the right way.
And,
um,
I alluded before when we talked about
the British identity in the 18th century,
I said with the British
in the 17th century,
what they weren't help determine who
they thought they were and what they
weren't was absolutist.
They reform what they weren't with Kath,
not they're not Catholic.
And the biggest riots in the 18th
century where the Gordon riots,
which were anti-catholic riots,
they are not the French,
not at all.
France has a centralized state and France
is full of Catholics and many of the
Protestants who would,
who had left France after the
relocation of the edict of not in 1685,
uh,
come not just to the Netherlands,
but come to a Britain as well.
So this may have already tipped you off
on who is the unwanted dangerous other
in the British,
particularly upperclass,
but not just a upperclass imaginary.
And they are the Irish Irish.
And so what happens in 1848
and the subsequent years
is that British nationalism
is redefined again or reinfused with a
sense of what we are not and we are not
Catholic and we are not Irish.
And so if there was going to be a
revolution in April or any other month in
1848,
the components would be from the point
of view of the upper classes and from the
police,
the Irish and um,
and groups of physical force chartists
or revolutionaries who might join forces.
Now Chartis look to Irish
to get them to sign a,
the big petitions they see them as allies.
And remember because of
the of the Irish famine,
potato famine in the 1840s,
that tens of thousands of Irishmen,
hundreds of thousands of Irishmen.
Indeed,
I think the,
I have it in the book somewhere,
but the number of people who leave Ireland
in 1840 is in the millions along with
all those who just simply die,
you know,
die in the fields and they go to where
they go to the United States and they go
to England,
particularly Liverpool.
It's why I Liverpool,
this has nothing to with
anything we have while Vec,
but the Liverpool soccer team
is very much perceived as,
you know,
a Catholic team in the way that in,
in Glasgow,
uh,
that the Celtics are the Catholic team
because so many Irish immigrants went to
Glasgow and to Scotland.
And the Rangers are the Protestant team,
very anti-catholic.
And that's why these people
were brawling in 1900.
They've played before
100,000 people in 1900,
100,000 people at a
soccer game in about 1900.
And they hate each other's
guts and they still do.
Um,
so all these Irish are
going to London also,
and they live in the Irish neighborhoods.
And so from the point of
view of the ruling classes,
uh,
and from the point of view of British
nationalism in front of the point of view
of the police,
the possibility was there that the
Irish can federation who are extremely
militant,
uh,
one of the important Irish leaders,
Daniel O'Connor,
a O'Connell,
Daniel O'connell who is in the book,
uh,
he dies in 1847 but you,
you've got these more people
that are far more militant,
uh,
who,
who believe in the only rate.
Many of them believed that the only way
Ireland is ever going to be independent
is by rising up and rebelling.
And that's what happens,
isn't it?
That's what eventually happens.
So they were right about that.
But what if they start rebelling in 1848?
And what if you had,
for example,
you had the,
your basic Peter Lou
massacre as they called it,
uh,
playing on the word Waterloo where the,
you know,
British troops shoot down a well dressed,
uh,
demonstrators,
in Manchester.
Uh,
what is it,
1817 or 1816,
1817.
I don't remember.
Um,
what if the people who said,
we ain't ever going to get anywhere if
we don't do what our French colleagues
have done and that is take
arms against these people.
So there is a potential for an alliance
between militant in the physical force
chartist movement,
uh,
you know,
other radicals,
uh,
and,
members of the Irish confederation
now because it never happens.
I mean,
there are a few marches,
there's a few skirmishes,
but basically the only news
is no news does not mean that,
uh,
that,
that this wouldn't have a big
effect on the reinvention of,
of British nationalism.
I'm British self identity.
And what do I mean by that here?
One of the interesting things is that a
John Belcher told me a long time ago on
a train,
uh,
in Germany,
from coming back from a
conference in Verse Berg,
that there were more boxes of
documents in the public record office,
uh,
about their surveillance of ships coming
into the ports of Port Smith and above
all Liverpool than there were any other
documents about any other aspect of
1848.
Why,
what are they doing?
Where is the potential insurgency or
infusion of militants for Irish coming
from?
It's coming from the United States.
And one of the interesting
things about this,
and you could see also in
that time of the troubles,
you know,
in the 1970 I was in Ireland,
ironically when they all
started up again in 1969,
um,
uh,
that,
you know,
when all this,
there was at a time they
were really worried about,
about,
about the IRA and there
was a lot to worry about.
Then the IRA was getting all sorts of
money from a Irish pubs in New York and
Boston,
just tons of money,
big bucks all the time to buy weapons.
Um,
now,
uh,
in 1848,
one of the interesting things that Belcher
and other people have discovered is
that the real Irish militants,
the most committed were Irish immigrants,
immigrants to immigrants from Ireland
living in Boston and New York.
And what they had done is taken the
notion of American liberty in quotes and
saying,
all right,
our role will be that of the French
revolution to carry liberty in principal
across the borders and Free Europe from,
uh,
from Knoebel's,
from priests,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Uh,
and what we will do as Irish,
first generation Irish living in New York
and Philadelphia and Boston and maybe
Connecticut too,
is we will,
uh,
we will raise money and we will make Irish
independence and we will achieve this
with violence,
with guns.
Uh,
and so every ship that came into any port
that was coming from the United States
was thoroughly searched for,
uh,
now for weapons and for money.
And so,
uh,
these,
these Irish immigrant immigrants
to the United States where,
uh,
we're the most militant,
arguably within the Irish,
uh,
um,
a political movement for independence.
Now,
for one thing,
they had more means.
Some of them have had come to Ireland,
I mean,
from Ireland come to the United States.
I'm maybe going through England,
maybe not,
but they had jobs and the,
and the people in Ireland
himself were just starving.
I mean,
they were dying in the fields.
Uh,
there were ending up in London,
living with other Irishman,
which is not surprising,
uh,
maintaining these kinds of,
of patterns by county,
Cork and all this.
Uh,
and,
and the Catholic Church was terribly,
terribly important,
uh,
in,
in their lives.
Terribly,
terribly important as you know,
means of charity and all of this.
But what it meant for the upper classes
is that the unwanted other Catholic,
remember Nate eight in 1798,
they tried to ally with the French.
What happens in World War One,
Roger Casement,
who was Irish militant,
who was absolutely against the
exploitation of workers in,
in,
in Peru and an African everywhere else.
Roger casement.
Uh,
you know,
he ends up being a,
being a set off with a little boat off
of submarine off the coast of Carrie.
And he tries to stop
the eastern selection.
And of course he's rested within
about 25 minutes and Hong later.
But what he had tried to do was,
was,
was organize in prisoner
of war camps in Germany,
Irish militants to fight the
good fight and to free Ireland.
So there was always,
this was again looking later,
but there was always this potential fear
among the British upper classes is that
they,
these Catholics who are no
longer just across the channel,
they're not,
you know,
over an Ireland across a very choppy,
gray freezing,
you know,
see,
uh,
they are living in Liverpool and huge,
huge numbers.
They are living in,
in,
in London and even bigger numbers and
they are there and they are dangerous.
And if they ally with these,
this satisfied workers from
the chartist movement movement,
all hell is going to break out.
And so during the next time,
and I don't have a,
I don't have much time at all but,
but just to,
to,
and I knew it didn't even
use this well anyway.
Um,
you see,
you see the point,
this potential alliance never occurs.
But one of the interesting things about,
uh,
the,
the reinvention or the reconstruction
of British new identity,
self identity,
and it's one shared not just
by nobles and big time Gentry,
but by ordinary workers,
Tory workers,
we tended to call them dismissively.
Uh,
those are those who can
stand Margaret Thatcher,
uh,
you know,
and always were amazed to go through it,
and working class parts of Britain and
see these miserable of council houses
when these big pictures of Margaret
Thatcher or the royal family,
you know,
anyway,
it's just amazing.
But,
but these Tory workers,
uh,
in,
not just Tory workers,
but they,
they,
they see themselves as respectable.
They see themselves as British and,
and they increasingly see this sort
of unwanted enemy within Catholic.
And I mean within as the Irish and the
newspapers are full of cartoons and
characatures of the Irish who are
portrayed in variably as drunken,
as stupid.
And as Lazy Patty,
Pa d d y becomes a for
the character trust in,
uh,
in British newspapers,
in 1848 and subsequent years,
uh,
he is portrayed,
Patty is portrayed as the
unwanted other who is a threat to,
and it has no place being in except to
do menial jobs or fat or fat as a factory
operative if,
if they,
uh,
if they maintain respectability and don't
try to out their Irishness too much.
And so if anyone wants to know why
these issues become so extraordinarily
bitter,
it almost anytime you can think of
all stir in the 70s ultra in the,
in the 80s,
I mean,
the 1970s,
in 1980s,
or even into the 1990s,
uh,
or,
Ireland in 1916,
uh,
1848 plays a major role in that.
Now,
this is not to say that all,
you know,
all people who saw themselves
as British were necessarily,
you know,
nasty,
aggressive people.
But it does simply remind us.
And here again,
I council Linda Colley's
book called Britain's,
uh,
as it very eloquent,
um,
you know,
summary of all of this,
uh,
that part of the construction
of any kind of identity.
And I'll talk more about this when I
talk about Eastern Europe and central
Europe is what you're not and what you're
not for the British in 1848 afraid of
catching this cold coming
from the continent was again,
uh,
you,
you are not French and
you are not Catholic.
And,
and this,
if anything was going to further sour,
uh,
the relations between Irish
and British authorities,
particularly given the fact that the
British Protestants own the land in,
in Ireland.
I was someplace the other
day and I heard a talk,
uh,
as in New York the other day and I heard
a talk in and saw some pictures of,
of these marvelous kind of called
mass or mass rocks that were in the,
uh,
in rural Ireland were,
were priests in the 17th and 18th century.
And in the 16th century for that matter,
at the end of the 16th century,
said mass in secret,
uh,
using the slab rocks,
rocks that they happen to find his alters.
Because,
because being practicing
your religion was,
was illegal.
And the Protestants have,
uh,
the law on their side and they own,
they own the land.
Anyway.
So 1848,
there was no revolution in,
in Britain in 1848.
Uh,
you know,
clearly why this is not the case.
Uh,
it's almost surprising to think that
they could have imagined that alliance
between the Irish Confederation
and other Irish groups,
uh,
and physical force,
Chartis,
uh,
but 1848,
has,
uh,
another,
role to play in British identity and
that I've tried to convey to you today.
Have a wonderful weekend.
See you on Monday.
Bye.